so
big question to start with here what
would you say is the
biggest difference between the way you
approached your work on the show day one
compared to the end like another tool in
the toolkit so to speak that you would
credit with working on sabrina
i know for me what that would be um
so i uh i learned a lot
from watching actors like michelle gomez
and richard coyle and miranda otto
but particularly in the beginning
michelle because
i've never seen someone so fearlessly
wild like in in her work her choices
were just
out there and big and brave
but never wrong um because she was
having fun you know it was never
it was never off it was always right on
you know just
the flavor was right so i think for me
something that i
learned how to do by the end was read it
and just be like
what do i want to do what do i think
would be funny how can i make this
really fun for me rather than
rather than trying to do it right
instead like
figuring out how much space i can take
up in this room and
you know really really taking my time
with things um
i i've definitely learned that on
sabrina i think you know in a like a
literal sense
um i specifically remember my very very
first day on set
i had to cry um it was it was part one
with my black eye
when we were walking um through the
parking lot of baxter high
and i was like i started the fight uh
that one and so i had to be like
actively sobbing having a panic attack
and
i at the time i was like oh then i
should just you know have a panic attack
so i just had like a six hour panic
attack because i thought that that's
what i was supposed to do
um at a little 16 year old i know how to
act kind of
headspace and then um one of my last
scenes on sabrina
is a really emotional one where we had
to shed some tears
and i just learned how to really trust
myself and to take care of myself
and to distinguish my job
from my uh my care my
myself my well-being um jazz said
something
uh earlier that michelle said um that i
may not say right but it was something
like our job is to um
protect our mental health and it's an
exercise and mental health it's an
exercise in mental health because it is
really tough um putting yourself in
those states and being away from your
family
um and i really learned how to manage
that and i'm really proud of myself for
that
i'm psyched to see where you guys both
take those uh those newfound skills from
here because
man am i gonna miss this show i love
science i love
offering it seriously and i've loved the
community that you built and the vibe
that you guys all
share behind the scenes as well has been
a really nice component of this